the families of two teenagers who were
shot and killed after allegedly
trespassing outside a home in Dayton
Ohio are demanding accountability the
homeowner admitted he shot jayveer
Harrison and Devin Henderson on
Wednesday police say the teens may have
been involved in drug activity on the
property
Nikki batiste is here Nicky why hasn't
the homeowner been charged well Adrianna
police are trying to determine whether
this is a case of justifiable
self-defense relatives of one victim say
the unidentified homeowner knew the
teens but police haven't confirmed that
a recent change in Ohio law could help
his case I want answers the father of
jayveer Harrison is wondering why a man
he says knew his son would kill him and
his friend so I felt like it was
premeditated it wasn't in your house it
was in the garage you seen some perps
out there at your garage you know so my
first instinct is called a police I feel
like you took DeLong to his own house
the homeowner told police he saw a light
in his garage Wednesday and found three
people sitting inside a car police say
he fired his revolver multiple times
killing the two teens the third person
ran away but returned when police
arrived it take time for us to comb
through the evidence to present at the
prosecutor's office and for them
determine whether in fact this is a
justifiable self-defense or whether this
is a criminal act
prosecutors have a high standard to
prove it was a crime just this year Ohio
joined many other states and requiring
prosecutors to prove a homeowner did not
act in self-defense while police asked
for patience during the investigation
the victims families want answers now
I'm broken I'm so broken police took the
homeowner into custody for questioning
but later released him they are still
combing through evidence and haven't
said whether the teens were armed but
the family of jayveer Harrison says he
never carried a weapon Gail Nikki thank
you